Hey Crazies.
There are 3 big misconceptions about the universe
people still don’t get.
Let’s set the record straight!
This episode was supported by Billiant.org
OK, so I have briefly mentioned some of these things in previous videos.
There’s a whole playlist on cosmology,
but I’m spastic sometimes, so I could believe
you might have missed them.
One!
How much bigger will I be at 80-years-old
after you account for the expansion of the
universe?
Exactly the same size.
Well, maybe not exactly the same size.
Most people are shorter when they’re older
because of biological changes.
But the expansion of the space has exactly
zero effect on your size.
Are you saying the universe isn’t expanding
inside us?
Oh, it is!
It just isn’t strong enough to stretch you.
Think of it like this.
Imagine you and the love of your life are
holding hands,
but you’re each standing on your own conveyor
belts that move in opposite directions.
You know, because the universe is always against
you.
Anyway, the belts try to pull you apart, but
they’re not strong enough to overcome the
grip you have on each other’s hands.
You stay together as the belts move beneath
you.
The force from your hands holds you together.
The same kind of thing happens with space
except in 3 dimensions.
Space stretches through you while you stay
the same size
because there are forces between your atoms
and molecules that hold you together.
They’re strong enough to overcome the expansion
of space.
Solar systems, galaxies, and even clusters
of galaxies are held together by gravity,
so they don’t expand either.
However!
The expansion of space is uniform throughout
the universe,
but gravity gets weaker with distance.
At a sufficiently large distance, the expansion
wins and can start spreading things out.
That happens between super-clusters of galaxies.
That’s clusters of clusters of galaxies!
The universe is big enough that one point
of light in this image is a super-cluster
of galaxies.
Space is big.
Really big.
Two!
Why does it look like we’re the center of
the universe?
Because we are the center
of the observable universe.
We can’t see the whole entire universe because
light doesn’t travel fast enough.
The universe might be infinite, it might be
finite, but either way,
Light hasn’t had enough time to travel all
the way across it,
so this is all we get to see of it.
That’s the observable universe.
That’s how far light could have possibly
traveled since the big bang.
And, this is the light that’s traveled the
farthest:
the Cosmic Microwave Background.
The observable universe and the entire universe
are not the same thing.
Unfortunately, some people call both
of these things “the universe”
and it causes a lot of confusion.
Anyway!
Since light takes the same amount of time
to travel from every direction,
we can see the same distance in every direction,
which makes us look like the center of the
universe.
Even though we aren’t.
Three!
How can a 3D universe be flat?
It’s not!
It’s not actually flat!
You know how words can have multiple meanings?
When we say the universe is flat, we’re
not using the word in an ordinary way.
These shapes are just visual representations
of math.
“Flat” just means “Zero Curvature.”
The universe doesn’t actually look like
any of these shapes.
Honestly, we should probably stop using them,
but people like pictures.
If you want to understand anything involving
general relativity, then remember this:
The easiest way to see curvature is by drawing
parallel lines.
For example, if you draw parallel lines on
a flat piece of paper
those lines will stay parallel across the
entire piece of paper.
If we live in a flat universe and the
data suggests that we do,
then parallel lines in our universe should
do the same thing.
Let’s say there are two spaceships.
Each ship plots out a course they think will
be parallel to the other ship’s course.
If the universe is flat, those courses will
stay parallel as the ships travel.
No matter how far they go, they’ll always
be the same distance apart.
What other option is there?
Oh! Oh! I'm glad you asked!
On a sphere like the Earth, two parallel lines
come closer together over time.
If the spaceships are flying in a positive
curvature universe,
then their paths will come closer together
over time.
On a saddle, two parallel lines spread apart
If the spaceships are flying in a negative
curvature universe,
then their paths will spread apart over time.
Planes, spheres, and saddles are just lower-dimensional
examples of curvature.
It’s the curvature that matters, not the
shape.
So I hope that clears things up!
As usual, if you have questions, please ask
in the comments.
Thanks for liking and sharing this video.
A special thanks goes out to Patreon patrons
like Daniel Bahr
whose regular support keeps the lights on
and the cloning machine working.
Don’t forget to subscribe if you’d like
to keep up with us.
And until next time, remember, it’s OK to
be a little crazy.
Watching YouTube videos is fun, but knowing
physics like I know it takes loads of practice!
If that sounds interesting to you, then check
out Brilliant.org.
Brilliant is a problem solving website designed
to train you to think like a scientist on
a wide variety of topics.
Oh look!
Here’s a course on Astronomy with a unit
on Cosmology.
Let’s try out the quiz on the “Shape of
the Universe.”
Hmmm, those shapes look oddly familiar.
Which sketch below shows where objects moving
directly away from each other would eventually
come back together again?
I bet you could answer that one after watching
this video.
If you find yourself struggling, that’s
ok.
Brilliant even has hints and solutions to
get you into that critical frame of mind.
It’s a great way to practice without too
much pressure.
Brilliant.org was nice enough to sponsor this
video and crazy enough to offer you a discount.
The first 200 people to visit Brilliant.org
slash Science Asylum will get 20% off an annual
premium subscription.
It’s a really good offer if you’re into
this sort of thing.
I wanted to just take a few seconds to thank
thedeemon for
diligently and accurately helping me answer
questions in the comments.
There’s just too many for me to answer by
myself.
Thank you
and thanks to everyone for watching.